earlier today the website WikiLeaks
released nearly 400,000 classified
military documents on the Iraq war they
reportedly revealed details concerning
thousands of previously unreported
civilian deaths and torture against
detainees by Iraqi authorities its
founder was among a panel who spoke at a
news conference in London to talk about
his group's findings this is an hour and
fifteen minutes of the Iraq war and
these releases are based on
and published by WikiLeaks you will have
seen the print of course and television
coverage this morning those speaking
this morning are Julian Assange the
editor of WikiLeaks which he founded in
2006 WikiLeaks has won a number of
awards including the index on Censorship
2008 economists no media award and an
award of distinction from the prions
electronica in June 2009 WikiLeaks and
Julian Assange want Amnesty
International's UK Media Award and July
this year he won the the Sam Adams Award
for integrity he's joined by Kristen
Hoffman who became actively involved
with WikiLeaks on the Collateral Murder
video earlier this year and traveled to
Baghdad on effect finding mission he has
20 years experience as an investigative
journalist with Channel 2 News which is
a private broadcaster and ruv the
Icelandic public brought a state
broadcaster he's been awarded twice
Iceland's highest journalism award after
WikiLeaks on the panel is John sue
Lovato since 2003 Jon has been
coordinator of the Iraq body-count
project an ongoing human security
project maintaining and updating the
world's largest public database of
violent civilian deaths since the 2003
invasion
he's a consultant and director of the
Oxford research groups recording
casualties in armed conflict program and
chairs the international advisory group
he is emeritus professor of psychology
at the University of Peel and an
honorary professor at the school of
politics and international relations at
Royal Holloway University of London the
Iraq body count data I should mention
has been used by an extraordinary group
of people the New York Times The
Washington Post The Associated Press
al-jazeera open democracy the
independent the Guardian the World
Health Organization the International
Criminal Court the New England
medicine and the European Union's joint
research center and the Brookings
Institute in Washington and at 10:25
we'll also be hearing from Phil sign
China Phil shiner leads the team at
Public Interest lawyers
he's been practicing as a solicitor in
the UK since 1981 and has written
extensively on international and human
rights law in recent years he has acted
in some of the most important judicial
review cases to be brought in his area
of expertise and in March 2010 he led
the team to success in the European
Court of Human Rights in a particularly
important case he was made a solicitor
of the Year by the way in 2008 and was
in the Sunday Times top 10 solicitors in
Britain in the same year so I think we
can now start with Julian Assange thank
you because we don't have much time I
won't speak for long but this disclosure
is about the truth Philip Knightley the
great investigative reporter an
Australian who for the past 30 or 40
years has made the UK his home said but
the first casualty of war is the truth
but the attack on the truth by war
begins long before war starts and
continues long after a war ends in our
release of these 400,000 documents about
Iraq war the intimate detail of that war
from the US perspective we hope to
correct some of that attack on the truth
that occurred before the war during the
war and which has continued on since the
war officially concluded in that
material the deaths of some one hundred
nine thousand people
documented internally declared 66,000
civilians working with the Iraq body
count we have seen that there are
approximately 15,000 never previously
documented or known cases of civilians
who have been killed by violence in Iraq
that tremendous scale should not make us
blind to the small human scale that
occurs in this material in fact it is
the deaths of 1 & 2 people per event
that kills the overwhelming number of
people in Iraq following our release of
the Afghan war Diaries we thought we
would try and pull together a broader
coalition not just involving print the
one that had the emotionality and impact
of TV journalism and extra research from
other groups so we structured a
collaboration between the Guardian
Spiegel New York Times our pre our three
previous print partners and new groups
the bureau for investigative journalism
iraq body count is knowledge of deaths
in iraq is unsurpassed svt the Swedish
television al Jazeera channel for BBC
radio and I'm sure I've missed some
others yes
Lamont
that collaboration seems to have worked
and we will see over the next few days
what's to be made of it but so far we
can see a fairly strong response we have
seen as of 3 a.m. this morning 1500 News
1,500 articles according to Google News
and of course all around the world we
can see the result we make a promise to
our sources who go through incredible
risks sometimes to get us material that
we will do justice to their efforts and
get them the maximum political impact
possible and while I'm not sure that we
have achieved the maximum possible I
think we're getting pretty close and
with that I'll introduce you now to
Kristen thank you when WikiLeaks
announced the release of the Afghan war
diary on July 26 the organization was
condemned by the Pentagon for releasing
material that was described as sensitive
and harmful both to Afghanistan T troops
in the country those overblown
statements were echoed in most of the
media without any criticism or critical
question three months have passed now
and there have been no reports of any
harm in relation to the release of the
Afghan war diary this has been now even
been acknowledged by the Pentagon last
week some news organizations obtained a
copy of a letter sent by US Secretary of
Defense Robert Gates to the heads of the
Senate Armed Services Committee although
it was 16 this was about the same time
the gates and pentagon spokesperson
we're sending out strongly worded
statements in the
Gillies indicates letter however it is
acknowledged that the outcome documents
had no not revealed any quote sensitive
intelligence sources or methods unquote
last week top NATO official reiterated
in a statement to the press that he had
not seen any harm as a result of the
release the contrast between a letter
decode by the NATO official and the
hyped statements by the Pentagon spokes
person should be a reminder that people
should not accept condemning statements
against WikiLeaks without question in
relation to the Afghan files WikiLeaks
with health one in six reports 15,000 in
all four line by line reviewing and
reduction that work is now finished and
reports will be released soon this time
weeklies took a new approach to delete
data to Reddit acting process it used an
electronic reduction method combined
with tests done by groups of people it
is in an innovative approach that has
been perfected by a group of people
contributing to the process it can best
be described as a reverse approach to
reduction at the outset everything in
all reports was deemed harmful and
reducted until proven otherwise from
their own words traces locations
observations etc were uncovered or
unredacted step by step the warp in the
past week has the week's have therefore
been focusing on minimizing the
reduction along the way batches of
documents were taken out and tested by a
group of qualified volunteers and the
further tests were done on the 390,000
documents we are confident now that the
documents in the highly
redacted form contain no information
that could
harmful to individuals having said that
I would like to add that every system
can contain floors that the likelihood
of any flaw in our processes you need
minimum the end result which we are
presenting is still in highly redacted
Kashyap documents despite the over
reductions the Warwick is easily
readable and can be data mined for news
new stories and angles for those
interested we will also look into the
possibility of providing news media and
academics access to unredacted parts of
the documents upon request furthermore
it needs to be emphasized that we aim to
continue on the track of further
minimizing the deductions but being a
small organization with limited
resources this could take some time
Thanks thanks Kristen you'll see on war
log stock wikileaks.org the interface
that kristen spoke of that emits
full text searching of the entire
reducted collection including boolean
terms you can search for keywords like
OG a of the government agency a
euphemism typically for the CIA or dia
we also partnered with avi to produce a
system where people who have information
about these events can comment on them
and rate them go to the website and have
a look at that there's a lot of
obviously there's a tremendous worldwide
interest at the moment so those those
systems may be slow but if you persevere
across the day you will find them to be
quite usable it's what we use fastly
internally and the Iraq our body count
also has a system which they'll describe
in any human disaster finding out who
died and how they died is the overriding
public concern seven years old the
public does not have a full account of
the terrible human cost of this ongoing
Iraq war to the Iraqi people what we
have instead is an incomplete patchwork
of stories pictures and data gathered by
different organizations for different
purposes often published one day and
forgotten the next the victims of this
war their families and the public's
whose taxes funded this war deserved
better than this there is a public right
to know Iraq body count has been working
on a daily basis since March 2003 to
ensure that no fact about a civilian
death that is uncovered is then lost
from view we carefully monitor compare
and analyze published reports mostly
provided by press and media
organizations such as are represented in
this room in this way we have been able
to build and keep in the public eye the
most detailed and comprehensive list of
civilian deaths to date that exists in
fact the world's press and media have by
default being the front line data
gatherers of this war without
journalists and without the
organizations for which they work the
world would know little of substance
about the Iraq death toll but
yesterday's release reveals that there
has been another front line data
gatherer the US Army day-by-day secretly
soldiers all over Iraq had been writing
detailed reports of the violent deaths
they caused witness or are informed
about dates times precise locations
names ages and occupations of victims
have all been stored away in these logs
it is very good that this data has been
collected but it is wrong and
unjustifiable but it has been kept
secret for so long
Iraq body-count has started the huge
task of integrating the new information
into the existing patchwork just as we
would for any other source
to our attention in the few weeks since
we've had access to the Lord's we've
only scratched the surface but by
careful sampling and matching of these
marks against what is already in our
database we have a clear emerging
picture of what these logs contain as a
whole and the reports on our website
here at wadi qelt org give the full
details but let me take you through the
headline findings I on my colleagues
hanate Darda gan Josh Doherty and Peter
Becnel will be available to answer
further default questions during and
after this press conference based on our
careful sampling we estimate that when
fully analyzed these logs will bring to
the public knowledge more than 15,000
previously unreported civilian deaths to
add to the 107 thousand which are
already in the iraq body-count database
15,000 is a huge number it's equivalent
to five 911s or nearly 300 7/7 however
the newly revealed deaths do not
primarily come from large bombings like
this most of the larger incidents were
already well reported by the world's
press and media the new deaths are
concentrated in small incidents killing
one or two people at a time scattered
all over Iraq on declaring almost every
day for the whole period target of
assassinations drive-by shootings
executions checkpoint killings these are
the small but relentless tragedies of
this war that these logs reveal in
unprecedented detail adding in the
combatant deaths reported in these logs
and combining with other previously
reported deaths we are now able to say
that more than a hundred and fifty
thousand people have been killed in
total since 2003 of which about 80% were
civilians even where deaths were
previously known about as numbers these
logs often turn numbers into human
beings
for instance the IVC database records
that on November the 1st 2006 35 bodies
were found around Baghdad that day as
reported for example by Reuters the New
York Times CNN among others however
media reports did not identify any of
the
nor give details of how each one died so
our IBC database has just this spare
information in it the Iraq war logs also
report 35 bodies found that day but
spread across 27 logs specifying a wide
range of details including the precise
neighborhood and time of day where
particular bodies were found and in many
cases the demographics and identities of
those killed
so when fully processed the information
in these logs will allow our single
entry to be replaced by over 20 detailed
incidents most surprisingly of all we
have found a huge number of names of
victims particularly recorded in these
logs it's unclear to us why the US Army
wanted to go to such lengths in its
recording but it is of huge public
importance and interest that it did
names are the gold dust of casualty
recording enterprise and the only
certain route to a full and final death
toll that will satisfy all parties
including bereaved families we've
already found over 100 previously
reported civilian victim names in the
logs we've examined and we estimate that
many thousands more will be discovered
as analysis proceeds for instance on
29th of November 2006 28 bodies were
discovered in the mass grave south of
Aqaba this was comprehensively reported
by press and media at the time but not a
single one of those reports gave the
names of a single victim the Iraq war
logs lists all these names one by one
and so today for the first time they
have been put into the public record
nearly four years later the
unprecedented level of detail in these
logs is important for another reason -
it's the main way in which we can
properly assess what is new in them the
crude death totals that these lot to
provide are lower than the comparable
count from IBC also lower than figures
from others providing totals such as the
Arad Ministry for Human Rights this can
tempt people to mistakenly assert that
there is nothing new in these logs our
analysis shows how hugely mistaken that
assertion is in conclusion we believe
that having received these logs
WikiLeaks was right to publish them in
this heavily redacted form but the real
story is not about the release
itself of the grave content of the logs
themselves almost every log tells a
story and far too often this is a
previously unknown story of human
suffering and death it will take many
months even years to extract every
important fact from these logs the Roth
word account is committed to playing its
part in this fact finding work no matter
how long it takes because there can be
no closure for moving on from this or
any war until every last victim has been
properly recognized and the full details
of the circumstances of their death
acknowledged these logs are potentially
the largest single contribution to
achieving that goal that has ever been
published we ask everyone including the
US government to support this work which
is in the public interest and brings
closer the proper recognition that all
the victims of this tragic war deserve
the question you're probably asking is
well what now and I'm going to tell you
about some of the legal action that will
follow here in the UK and it'd be wrong
to assume that as as these are us logs
this has nothing to do with the UK
public interest lawyers it's presently
active for many Iraqi civilians who've
been killed or tortured by UK forces
some have been killed by indiscriminate
attacks on civilians or the unjustified
use of lethal force others have been
killed in custody with UK forces no one
knows how many Iraqis lost their lives
whilst held in British detention
facilities the most notable of those of
course is Parham is de and we now await
inquiries report into his death jus in
early 2011 the Iraq war logs add hugely
to the evidence and in the public domain
as to the effect of the invasion and
subsequent occupation of Iraq by
coalition forces including the UK what
can be said about the logs comes under
three headings all three areas are or
will sue me the subject of legal action
here in the UK the first is that of
unlawful killings or civilians or
indiscriminate attacks upon them or the
unjustified use of lethal force against
them it may never be known how many
Iraqis died but we now know from the
important work of him bodycam that the
previously known number of death 107,000
369 is likely to have increased by
around a staggering 15,000 some of these
deaths will be in circumstances where
the UK had a very clear legal
responsibility this may be because the
Iraqis died whilst under the effective
control of nuke a forces under arrest
increases helicopters or detention
facilities these deaths will all fall
within the jurisdiction of the European
Convention on Human Rights if the
judgment of the ground chain
in the our tiny case which is too early
in 2011 asserts as we expect that once
UK forces have Authority and control of
Iraqis there is jurisdiction for the
purposes of the European Convention but
others will not be covered by the
European Convention on Human Rights for
example Public Interest lawyers as a
case where a UK tank stopped and in
broad daylight a rifleman aimed shot and
killed an eight-year-old girl playing in
her yellow dress in a Basra Street there
are many other cases like that and the
logs add to the number of cases that
will not be within the jurisdiction of
the European Convention but we will
argue in a case surely that the common
law here in the UK provides the same
remedy as the European Convention namely
that there must now be a judicial
inquiry into the legality of all of
these deaths if I'm justified or
unlawful force has been used
prosecutions of all those responsible
must follow it so we're bringing forward
a new case seeking accountability for
all unlawful deaths and we argue that
there must be judicial inquiry to fully
investigate UK responsibility for
civilian deaths in Iraq the second area
is the huge number of logs that detail
horrendous torture and abuse of Iraqis
by either the Iraqi National Guard or
the Iraqi police service the US and the
UK appeared to have adopted a fragmented
order that required them to take no
action whatsoever once they'd
established that this torture nil
treatment was the responsibility of
Iraqis now this is completely contrary
to international law it's well known
that there's an absolute prohibition on
torture it may never be used accordingly
all the states our duty to each other to
cooperate together to stamp it out and
to deal with incidents of torture
so that tortures know beforehand that
they will be found out
and they will be prosecuted for their
war crimes US and UK forces cannot turn
a blind eye on the basis it wasn't their
soldiers doing the torturing and that's
what's happened and that is revealed in
these logs both states are the clearest
of international obligations to take
definite and effective action to stop
the torture by the Iraqis that they did
not make them complicit pillared bring
for a second case seeking accountability
for the UK's failure to act in these
circumstances the third area concerns a
huge and growing body of evidence about
killings ill-treatment and torture of
Iraqis whilst in UKaid custody there
appear to be many cases other than that
sabaha mesa where a rockies died in UK
custody and were then certified as dying
from natural causes
none of these investors none of these
deaths have been investigated many of
these Iraqis were hooded and abused and
my law firm does not accept the Ministry
of Defense's explanation that each and
every one of these deaths has an
innocent explanation additionally there
are hundreds of Iraqis now complaining
of ill treatment and torture often as a
result of coercive interrogation
techniques by UK interrogators within
secret facilities run by the joint
forward interrogation team insofar as
the logs add to this body of evidence
they will help help us gain a single
inquiry into the UK's detention policy
and practice in South East Iraq a Court
of Appeal and High Court judge sitting
together will hear a case about all of
these incidents on the 5th to the 9th of
November 2010 very quickly now for
questions
but we have a surprise sort of
announcement and an unusual announcement
because we have an unusual addition to
the speakers this morning we have here
in the front row probably the most
famous whistleblower in modern American
history Daniel Ellsberg author of the
Pentagon Papers and we'll hear from him
shortly I would request though in during
the questions that all the questioners
on to understand that the speakers are
pleased to answer any in all questions
concerning the release of the documents
the analysis of the data and conclusions
and the work that's been done but I
think I'd like to if I may just to open
the questions by asking Daniel Ellsberg
Ellsberg what's your reaction to this
kind of release of material it's quite
different than the one that you did
yourself well it's different and it's
the same in many ways just as the war
that we're facing right now the one in
Afghanistan which I call Vietnam a stand
there's really more fundamental
similarities and I've had differences
I've been asked here to make a couple of
comments rather than questions to right
away well to say that a couple of us
here came over the ocean last night for
the opportunity to stand with Julian
Assange and circumstance that really
I've been waiting to see for 40 years
and I that's a number is not drawn out
of the air that's a precise figure Judy
Eric makes me just co-directed a film
called the most dangerous man in America
so she's working now on a selma hopes
the film on Julian Assange and his
sources and I haven't talked through
what the title was be but it seems
inevitable the most dangerous man in the
world now how do you get to be the most
dangerous man in the world well first
empirically if one country our country
in this case is pursuing for prosecution
that person regards him as dangerous
over three continents at this point in
Australia and Britain and America the
threat is made made by the Pentagon as
we read over the last few days
of warning newsmen to stand away from
this material to refuse to receive it
and if they do receive it to return it
seems absurd on his face we're not
dealing with the 7000 pieces of paper
top-secret pieces of paper that
comprised the pentagon paper the
Pentagon did make a demand the New York
Times that they returned that pile of
paper to the to the new Pentagon The
Times refused and until in fact never
did return it and refused to stop the
presses until a court order came down
but with cyber material it's all over
the world right now and several papers
right now the demand seems absurd I
understand the reason for those words
because they echo the words of the words
first used against me the legal words of
18 USC 793 paragraphs D and E which for
the first time used the so-called
Espionage Act as if it were the kind of
Official Secrets Act that you have in
Britain which simply criminalizes the
release of any classified material to
any unauthorized person we don't have
such a law and irony now is that
President Obama in making these clear
threats of applying this law to anybody
who deals with this information
including not only the journalists but
the word supply to the people who read
it and don't return it to the proper
authorities actually President Obama's
threats are not entirely without
credibility here because he has started
as many prosecutions for leaks as all
previous presidents put together it's a
small number it's three the last firm is
bradley manning it's small because we
don't have an official secrets act and
prior to bush and obama presidents took
it for granted that any application of
the Espionage Act was likely to be
overthrown as unconstitutional in our
First Amendment by the Supreme Court but
now facing a different Supreme Court and
after 9/11
Obama is making a new experiment on this
issue which will really change the
relation of the press to sources very
radically as it is any source with or
without this change in the law who gave
this kind of material four hundred
thousand pages documents eight hundred
thousand pages to WikiLeaks would have
to know that they were facing a risk of
being where Bradley Manning is right now
in prison accused of these things and we
don't know I don't know who the source
is if the president should prove beyond
reasonable doubt that it is Bradley
Manning we can give him his unreserved
admiration from us and thanks for what
he did but whoever did it in fact acted
very appropriately in the course of a
hopeless deadly stalemated war and which
has one characteristic by the way in
Iraq which isn't going to come out
clearly in these four hundred thousand
pages or in the discussion and that is
that the origins of the war were clearly
in the form of lying to the public's of
Britain and America and of carrying on
in the order to carry on a clearly
illegal crime against the peace a war of
aggression
so all these civilian casualties are
killed in a war of aggression it won't
have to say also the non civilian
casualties that are reported here are in
the role of fighting against foreign
occupiers invaders and by the standards
of the world the question is raised very
much whether they're death by the
invader is not also to be counted among
the murders until they continue so I
want very much to congratulate all of
you who are mining this material for the
to learn what we could have learned if
it had come out earlier
oh okay yes Craig Murray here is
representing a group that was mentioned
earlier I mentioned earlier giving the
Sam Adams Award for intelligence
integrity and we want very much to
appreciate him in that time thank you
I'm here as a forum and recipient of the
Sam Adams Award for intelligence the
integrity and intelligence my name's
Craig moly I was British ambassador in
Pakistan before I made a series of leaks
about use of air K intelligence sources
use of torture this award has been given
to a number of people including lasts to
Colonel Darly Wilkinson in the UK to
major thank Greville - Katherine Gunn of
GCHQ it's given to people who in the
public interest leaked details of the
dark things that governments do I'm very
happy to present this year's award to
Julian Assange
I think we'll take questions now from
the floor right right down there go
ahead Nikhil Chandler from The Daily
Star Sunday I just like to ask Phil
shiner you mentioned a forthcoming case
involving deaths and torturing of Iraqi
civilians in British detention how many
deaths you talking about
further you mentioned the young girl
getting shot by a squaddie in its hand
could you give us any more details on
that where and when did that happen I'll
do my best on both questions on the 20th
of May 2003 left-hander colonel Nicholas
Mercer a UK Army officer who was head of
army legal wrote an order that says
chillingly to all the troops who were
there they've recently been a number of
deaths of Iraqi civilians in custody
with various units now the MOT of lied
ever since when panorama trying to find
out what did Mercer mean by a number
they said - it's not - it's probably
seven or eight and it may be more but
that was the 20th of May 2003 the
ongoing disclosure in the Bahamas and
Corey keeps turning up more and more and
more cases where the Royal Military
Police have investigated deaths where
there's a common pattern often these men
are arrested and subjected to the severe
abuse on arrest in their homes sometimes
women and children are abused and
sometimes pregnant women have given
miscarriages etc then these men are
abused rifle butted hooded sometimes
with two hoods in the extreme conditions
and unsurprisingly they die and every
time they die it's said that they've
died of a heart attack or natural causes
they've never been seen by a UK doctor
usually somebody has accepted somebody
else's word or something that's been
written down on a piece of paper
so I can't tell you how many Iraqis we
killed whilst we held them in UK
detention facilities you'll have to ask
the Ministry of Defense that question as
to the bismillah girl
it was habit for her and her young
friends to play in the street and often
UK tanks would stop and get out and
trying to win the battle for hearts and
minds that would give the children
sweets on the particular morning in
question for some unknown reason that's
never been explained so I can't tell you
the tank stops at the end of the street
she's there in her yellow dress a
rifleman pops up and blows away and
you'll have to ask the Minister of
Defence
why that happened because they won't
tell me and that's one of the reasons
and one of the cases why we are calling
for judicial enquiry into all of these
deaths
Deborah Haynes for the times and this is
a question for Julian of the Pentagon
spokesman saying or said last night that
the names of 300 Iraqis have been
released as part of the Iraq war logs
and their lives could now be in danger
and are you worried that the careful
vetting that you outlined this morning
and maybe wasn't careful enough and
people's lives would be put at risk no
I'm worried that the press chooses to
credibly report statements like that
from the Pentagon in fact the Pentagon
would not have been able to review our
material in those few hours it is simply
logistically impossible and we also have
strong confidence in our redaction
process which is an opt-in process so
that statement by the Pentagon
presumably at its base is referring to
there
own internal review of their collection
of significant actions for Iraq is not
referring to our material but you will
notice that they do not say that fact
instead they try and issue some
deceptive statement to fool the world
press as they did last time with some
similar statements into reporting
something that is not true Paul Harrison
from Sky News Julian
you said in your opening statement that
you make a promise to all your sources
that you will in quotes do them justice
to all their for all their efforts but
given that we've seen her very much a
shrugging shoulders attitude or turning
a blind eye from the Americans thus far
according to these documents will that
not continue and therefore the efforts
of your sources may well largely be in
vain or have you had positive noises
from the US already that's the
interesting question as to how
responsive government is to the
condemnation of its people and the
rights of other people but the shrugging
of shoulders is of course the second of
powerful people the first arm is silence
so we've gotten beyond silence and now
we see an attempt to act in a nonchalant
manner about something that is very
serious that does not mean that it is
not treated seriously rather there is or
at least was certainly early on with the
Afghan material and attempts to make it
look like it would not be treated
seriously to frame
material as if it was of no consequence
I highly recommend a Daily Show episode
which collected all those there's
nothing new in this material reports for
Afghanistan and as it has turned out of
course that is not true in fact
according to Pew Research total war
reportage in the United States for that
week increased 300% from 6% to 18% the
approval rating for the Afghan war
decreased approximately 15% and Barack
Obama's personal rating at depending on
which poll you read decreased somewhere
between four and eight percent so those
are only of course crude figures that
speak about the whole rather than
individual cases that we can see
continual reportage was far away
high-quality reportage in the past two
weeks from Norway and expresso and Italy
based them on that Afghan material a
number of parliamentary inquiries I will
be speaking at the UN early next month
in relation to the Afghan material so I
expect the same thing to happen for this
material from them for Iraq and maybe
even more we're talking about five times
the number of deaths in the same period
we've also put together I think a much
stronger coalition a much broader
coalition at this time involving not
just print organizations but human
rights groups and lawyers and so on so I
think we're going to see some concrete
effects if not just the perceptual
effects about how wars are conducted an
interesting note is that and when I made
the opening about the truth being the
first casualty of war
we actually see that most wars that have
started by democracies involve life
vietnam war on the Gulf of Tonkin
incident involved live that started the
Iraq war involved very serious lies
which were repeated and amplified by
some parts of the press which leads us
to say what not that isn't the world
terrible because there's a lot of lying
by officials but rather leads us to a
great hope that democracies don't start
wars
unless there's Liars so there's enough
truth early on and off then perhaps we
won't see these kind of wars
wait I said hi question for Julian's ed
Cesar from The Sunday Times it's
business suggestions in the hacking
community that the systems that
WikiLeaks use users don't offer sources
the full protection that you advertise
on the side can you comment on that
there is a lot of tabloid press
surrounding our organization and of
course every organization that has a
high profile is involved in
controversial activities I have seen no
reports that are credible
that you've gathered how would you
characterize the conditions that existed
in Iraq in the time period that you're
reporting on oh I think John is probably
the best placed could you assure
yourself first I'm sorry would you mind
you prefer the more ignorant opinion but
I'll let John answer first and if he
misses something that I'll call our
focus is entirely on the victims and
those who died so what we can see but it
is simply a finer detailed picture of
what was actually all very already very
well known by the world at large in
press and media is this relentless grind
of daily killings day by day in almost
every town every province in Iraq of
checkpoints killings drive-by shootings
with with no end and the effect that
that must have on the ordinary Iraqi
people is just uncalculated in regard to
the other kinds of information the logs
torture and other observations which we
have nothing to say at this point
Christian okay
this question that felt on the
importance of the government are
granting a full traditional
investigation if that doesn't happen
will they take each case on an
individual basis and string this out for
a decade and more therefore less
lessening the impact of it so the
government coming round and granting
that invest additional review is crucial
to your table to your processes it is
the government's position is that it can
deal with one case at a time and each
case will take a year we have 142
outstanding cases so that will take 142
years the alternative is for the
administrative court here in London to
put teams of judges in two courtrooms to
deal with these cases within a proper
timescale both of those we say absurd
that the only rational solution to all
of these cases is to get it over with
and hold a proper inquiry along the
lines of the Baha Moosman quarry which
is just concluded and the mo D really
need to stop covering up which they do
with greater and greater desperation
slurring every one that they possibly
can we all know that something well many
things went badly wrong in Iraq we know
from the barn which inquiry for instance
that we should have had a detailed
interrogation DET directive in force in
Iraq that directive would have told
interrogators what they could and more
importantly what they could not do the
mo D in the by omission qui se we're
very sorry we didn't have one and we're
very sorry also that that meant that the
interrogators fell back on training
techniques from Chicksands and we're
also very sorry to admit that the
training was completely unlawful it
involved
forced nudity keeping people naked if
they wouldn't cooperate harshing
invasion of intimate space the use of
threats one man said to the bio museum
quarry the only limits on coercion were
the limits of one's imagination and I'm
not going to try and explain the
horrendous things that people did to my
clients when they let their imagination
run wild a lot of it involves pedophilia
images hardcore pornography sexual
intercourse and sexual acts in front of
my clients etc etc etc you simply cannot
say this is all down to a few bad apples
a few rogue soldiers a few isolated
incidents it's horrendous it's being
covered up and you the press are often
the people who allow it to be covered up
because you simply don't run the stories
you're obsessed some of you with what we
might have done in Pakistan or what we
might have known in Guantanamo Bay I say
to you wake up and have a look at what's
happening in our hike or next month on
November the fifth about what we
actually did
we intend to open that inquiry and
reveal material which no one has yet
seen about the way in which we
interrogated people I invite you to turn
up in force in the High Court on
November 5th and find out what the UK
actually did and stop going on about
what we might have done or what we might
have known about what the US were doing
because I can tell you a comparison of
what we did we've emerged some always
evidence which I have to say none of my
clients ever have been found to be
embellishing the truth let alone lying
they've all been found to be telling the
truth so I invite you to come along and
find out what we actually did and just
for one month stop going on about what
we might have been complicit in
Micajah flu mom don't you have unlike
Afghanistan that on Iraq the public
opinion and stern the page we've been
lied on but goes on the economic problem
at the moment and that there isn't the
interest for Iraq that they was on
Afghanistan this summer well for
Afghanistan we had 14 pages of The
Guardian for Iraq we have 90 and I
suspect that's probably a proportionate
view in the United Kingdom's press about
the relative importance but Iraq is now
just cool enough although remember
there's still 50,000 US troops there and
and something like a hundred and fifty
thousand a hundred thousand contractors
Iraq is now cool enough at least in the
public imagination to properly take a
look at it and that's not something that
is yet possible with Afghanistan we we
did a little bit of that with the Afghan
warlord release because it was a primary
source documentation but otherwise views
about patriotism and supporting of
troops and so on interferes with the
process for Iraq I can see already in
the news rapportage a much fairer and
less defensive portrayal of what
happened what happened in Iraq that has
been revealed by this release so these
two countries do not stand in isolation
these are both modern Western Wars and
the lessons of Iraq which are ongoing
remember this material covers
significant abuses occurring during the
first year of the farmer administration
can be applied to Afghanistan and can be
applied to other places that Western
governments may choose in isolation or
in coalition to invade the war itself in
the United States I think is becoming
more of an issue the Republicans are
using the mismanagement of the Afghan
war against the Democrats where one week
before the congressional elections and
the Democrats can point to rightly the
terrible abuses that occurred under
Republican Republican administration I I
hope that will permit raising of this
issue but I think in the last 24 hours
the the press has been I'm doing
precisely what they should and there's a
good and broad spectrum and you know the
press when it concentrates on a press
issue can overplay things but I think on
their response to this issue has been
broad and proportionate and will
continue yeah Anthony Faiola with the
Washington Post can you detail the steps
the additional steps that you took
between the release of the afghan
documents and these documents in terms
of redaction and to make sure that names
etc were not released well I think
Kristen covered that pretty well but the
the to make it simple cause it's a lot
of really long and complex
process which I can speak about later to
some of you but not not so we don't bore
the room the fundamental principle was
to start with everything every single
word and number redacted and then to
wind that back by finding safe words and
then modifying the safe words and
phrases for the rare accounts where
there were dual meanings of words and
that process also involved some of the
investigative journalists and
researchers consulting with us to give
us a feel for what sort of information
needed a special care although I must
say in that process the human rights
groups were very helpful and the bureau
diversity of journalism was also helpful
but none of the mainstream press
partners in fact provided any assistance
whatsoever to the demands to get 400,000
very serious documents into the public
record and into history where they can
have ongoing effect oh and if I may add
the Pentagon of course refused it it's
stated was we are not interested in a
conversation about harm minimization we
are only one wanting to hear how the
documents will be returned and the legal
counsel for the DoD also issued that
statement to us in private
correspondence yeah right back there
Rico Frenchie skinny from La Repubblica
Italy
Julian sometimes you're portrayed like a
man on the run are you worried about
your safety you do you think that your
enemies are trying to hurt you to get
you well I think I think that questions
been answered a lot in the past I mean
if you have anything you want to say to
it
well I mean I can only sort of get
people to consider the words of Daniel
Ellsberg that we have a a serious case
here where the Obama administration is
trying to create new law through
changing interpretation of existing law
in a similar manner to I suppose the way
in which Bush expanded the power of the
presidency using lawyers to create a new
interpretations of previous arrangements
and that's as that is a serious business
that applies not just to me but the
statements made by the Pentagon are
trying to be applied to all press in the
United States and outside the United
States and moving from computer world in
Wednesday you wrote on your Twitter feed
that WikiLeaks communications
infrastructure was under attack
do we have any evidence log files IP
addresses which could help of pinpoint
who was making these attacks and can you
elaborate a bit more what this attack
was about that matter is still being
investigated and I think he's perhaps
too far removed from the subject of this
conference
Julian back in summer I had the feeling
you or you said you know you wanted the
truth to come out which you still want
to but I have the feeling now that where
you said you know a lot of wars are
started by democracies you hope that
this procedure might stop that happening
in the future
so has your aim broadened altogether no
we're pursuing the agenda that we have
always perceived hold on a microphones
coming home to you there okay go ahead
hi Ann macmillan Canadian Broadcasting
you mentioned that you hope the lessons
will be learned from Iraq what would you
say are the main lessons that have come
through these four hundred thousand
leaked documents it's too early to tell
you it is the responsibly of the press
and the opportunity of the press and
human rights groups and legal outfits to
in fact draw those conclusions but I
mean Iraq as we can see was a bloodbath
on every corner of that country
the stated aims for going into that war
of
the rule of law did not eventuate and in
terms of raw numbers of people
arbitrarily killed worsened the
situation in Iraq
but it's a microphone right over here
Thanks
two columns who judged Saito magazine
from Munich Germany and your press
release you stated that it gives a the
currently gives a pretty good account of
the war in Iraq without the month may
2004 and March 2009 why we don't know
why those months are missing it's
important to remember that this material
while the most comprehensive and
detailed report of any war to ever have
entered into the public record is far
from complete it is based upon the
statements of US soldiers who are often
in a position where they have incentives
to lie such as when they're reporting on
their own activities and no one says I
unlawfully killed a civilian in the
right right to report about it
it is only material that is of the
secret level or below events which were
subsequently classified as top secret
are not present yeah
it doesn't cover US Special Forces it
doesn't cover the CIA it doesn't cover
the military activities of any other
nation in the coalition partnership all
the activities of the Iraqi army except
where the regular United States Army
interfaces with them so sometimes the
regular US Army will pull security for
the CIA engaging combined operations
with the Iraqi army with US Special
Forces with UK forces so we get good
small glimpses through a corner of a
window for those organizations involved
in the Iraq which are not the US Army
proper so we do glimpse their activities
but this is not a full account of their
activities it is a pretty full account
of the activities of the US Army
we've got we've got time for one further
question I'll actually pass it over to
you right here marry modify so America
this is a question I'm asking anyone on
the panel about we the press why do you
think it's easier for us to cover things
like rape as a tool of war in places
like West Africa and other places around
the world where it's been widely
documented as opposed to some place like
Iraq one of the things that we have to
face up to when we say they cleared the
bar how much inquiry is a historic
British colonial savagery if I can put
it like that the techniques that we were
using in the Musel incident putting
stress positions food and water
deprivation sleep deprivation the use of
noise those all go all the way back to
mandated Palestine through all the
colonial wars Cyprus Malaya Aden Kenya
and into Northern Ireland and you might
think that when Ted Heath bandage in
1972 it stayed banned no not to salt if
you look at what the British did in an
Iraq
it's the savagery these Iraqi men simply
did not exist they had been completely
dehumanized now my take is one of the
reasons the press are largely silent on
all of this is we just don't want to
face ourselves that's my take on the on
the on the British position and what we
did in Iraq you'd have to ask the
Americans for their tape but I think
it's important that there's a horrendous
racism and it's we see it in the British
Army we see it very clearly in the
vehemence inquiry and I think we can see
it very clearly in everything that it's
going to come out when we get this case
heard next next month and again I invite
Kress particularly to pay attention to
this case it's important okay we
actually have one or two more minutes
left it was a hand over here was secrecy
is essential to Empire and what I was
saying earlier was the United States
right now no doubt is declining in
various ways but not in intention and
under Obama as under Bush we are moving
more toward the British system of
control of information which is after
all the Official Secrets Act which is a
legacy of Empire and where that torch is
passing the Republican administration a
Republican House and Senate if that
comes into being in the next month
is almost certain to pass a british type
Official Secrets Act essentially ending
leaks of the sort we've seen over the
last 40 years 60 years which means that
WikiLeaks becomes more indispensable
than it has been it becomes the future
of unauthorized disclosure it will
become more and more important to make
these disclosures anonymously and what
has to be disclosed as I was saying
honestly WikiLeaks is not sufficient
what we've seen so far is not what we
need it's only a beginning it's not the
Pentagon Papers strictly speaking we
still need the Pentagon Papers of
Afghanistan and of Iraq on the
decision-making and the accountability
but for that matter the Pentagon Papers
were very inadequate too they weren't
the White House Papers the CIA papers it
took this generation to get most of
those and we haven't had any of it
really on the later wars since so what
we need is the closest to it in a way
other classified documents that were
shown to Bob Woodward for his latest
book so possibly Woodward could
contribute to the net all the documents
he was shown top-secret that would come
close to being the Pentagon Papers of
the White House papers of Afghanistan
would be very worthwhile short of that
one of his researchers could give those
documents to Wikileaks and that would be
very worthwhile and if not one of his
research
somebody in the administration should
give that type of material to WikiLeaks
bradley manning is accused of doing what
he could at the field level at the risk
of his life very admirably he's a hero
in my opinion to end this war he did
what he could
what's needed is for people who have
access to information that will help us
understand this war in a way that will
enable us to stop it to show us what
they know with documents and actually
WikiLeaks offers itself as the best
vehicle for their doing that what we're
going to do now is not run a photo call
which was booked here for simple reasons
of time now because it's gone over quite
considerably but we have a short film
produced by WikiLeaks to help to explain
some of the technical issues involved in
reading the documents it's a very short
film but might be helpful to you because
it comes from a knowledge of those
documents directly you cancelled it so
ok we are not going to see it there
that's that's all that's the one
he did the film or not shut up okay
let's do it yeah okay sorry it's gonna
happen this is what wikileaks.org
it is the interface to explore and
analyze these 400,000 classified
documents about the war in Iraq it is a
similar interface to what we produced
subsequent to our initial release for
Afghanistan a bit a bit more
sophisticated and able to handle many
tens of thousands of people
simultaneously so this is the website
you can see automatic graphing of
particular elements you can search by
keyword here's an example of selecting
one of the categories on the side that
is produced by the US military these are
types regions attacks on type of units
and several other categories that are
not produced by us but they're the
internal military categories by clicking
on these you will see them appear here
these are bullying so this is an and the
records must have both of these type
criminal event region Baghdad this is
multinational division Baghdad and this
is a list of reports with sort of
keywords in context the underscores our
redaction
and this is looking a bit further down
on the side panel here so you can see
graphs a number of documents for
American fuels those civilians killed
dates host nation killed host nation
wounded friendly killed
etc quite quite a few of these very easy
to use here's an example of going into a
particular record so bodies found in a
car in the vicinity of Baghdad that you
clicked on here expand acronyms very
important otherwise this is almost
completely unreadable and here it isn't
read for things that are expanding
acronyms killed in action would have
been ki a died of wounds vo w and on the
left the the structured data are
concerning this event and we'll go down
a bit this one's quite interesting here
it's not often used but this is critical
incident reporting sometimes will
include a field which is may cause
international media reportage so
actually if you want international meet
something to report
you just hunt on this field and they've
done part of the work for you in some
cases obviously some units where they
are involved themselves in a crime don't
like to suggest that they have done so
through the use of this field
this is a slightly more interesting one
a full-text search for OG a sometimes
appear sometimes appears here as a type
of unit Oda stands for other government
agency it's an internal euphemism for
the CIA or the Defense Intelligence
Agency typically the CIA and so you can
find at the CIA related records small
arms fire attack on Ogier convoys
Baghdad is my expanding acronym is here
you can see this
unfortunately the reduction is in fact
far far too heavy but was necessary to
prevent any sort of political attack
it's trapped from the real issue as time
goes by and we work through this
material manually we will be able to
decrease levels the reduction but in
this reports not too bad it's mainly the
names and some specific locations that's
it okay still to come on see